foreign
this morning at the White House one of
the first black officers in the Army's
Elite Green Beret will receive the Medal
of Honor for his heroism in Vietnam
nearly 60 years ago retired Colonel
Paris Davis's nomination for the
nation's highest combat declaration
mysteriously vanished not once but twice
at the height of the Civil Rights
Movement Davis and those who advocated
for him suspect that race was a factor
here reporting by a senior investigative
correspondent that's Catherine Herridge
helped bring this story to the
pentagon's attention she spoke with
Colonel Davis about what this honor
means to him
Colonel Davis when you first arrived in
Vietnam did you ever expect your journey
would end at the White House
never I see you there yeah around their
dining room table retired Green Beret
Paris Davis and his daughter Reagan
Hopper revisit old memories as they
prepare to make new ones at this
morning's Medal of Honor ceremony it's a
shame that it took this long 58 years
for Dad to be recognized with a medal
that he was completely worthy of but my
family hopes that in some small way it
could just help us all heal some of the
divisions in this country
Northeast of Saigon near bangsan hit by
a grenading gunfire in the Battle of
bangsang in Vietnam Davis saved the
lives of two of his troops and ignored
an order to evacuate as he told an
up-and-coming local TV host Phil Donahue
well I told him sir I'm just not going
to leave I still have an American out
there Davis's commanding officer Billy
Cole nominated him for the nation's
highest military decoration the Medal of
Honor but then the records mysteriously
vanished a 1969 military review did not
reveal any file on then major Davis
Reagan was race a factor I don't know
I suspect it might have been and I think
that's a shame
discrimination hurts us all not just the
individual but our entire country
so I'm so proud of us to finally set
this right
that took the work of this diverse group
of volunteers many who didn't know Davis
but worked to revive his case all those
people that had made it possible for me
to go to the White House we'll just get
there together I see some Tears In Your
Eyes Colonel Davis yeah it's it's really
very emotional the nomination was
recommended by senior defense officials
and ultimately approved by President
Biden who personally called Davis
the ongoing reporting of CBS News kept
the Davis case in front of decision
makers and brought new information to
light but the 1965 battle what
difference did CBS News make it was as
silent as the middle of the night until
CBS came along and made it happen this
week Davis received a new uniform for
the ceremony what does it mean to have a
new uniform long time coming I
Hallelujah are you still the same size
still the same size good yeah yeah I'm
surprised too
today Davis becomes one of just 65
living Medal of Honor recipients he says
he shares it with his special forces
troops all the other soldiers that
you've been working with and fighting
with somehow they need to touch that
metal
you know it ain't all yours it's for
America too
with today's award Colonel Davis
receives a new pension backdated to 1965
and after all these years Colonel Davis
told CBS News he remains grateful for
his army family and the doors that were
open to him flat
and Catherine I know this has been
personal for you you've been on this
story for quite some time thank you very
much for your reporting we really
appreciate you and your whole team as
silent as the middle of the night until
CBS came along that's you bravo bravo
Catherine Bravo and congratulations to
Colonel Davis and congratulations to
daughter Reagan number one what a Class
Act what a Class Act she is all of her
comments today and Reagan can I say your
dad is so cute this is as we see it's
never too late to do the right thing
such a great story so happy for your
family today